nous sommes rendus à paris match nous
avons rencontré des photographes
paris match c'est l'un des plus anciens
magazines de presse hebdomadaire en
france sa devise à sa création en 1949
le poids des mots le choc des photos
mais attention pas question d'être un
paradis pour autant d'ailleurs en 1964
daniel camus il reporter à paris-match
critiqué ces voleurs d'image
d'abord ce sont des gens qui travaillent
individuellement un seul et qui sont
obligés de chercher par n'importe quel
moyen
la bonne photo qui fera scandale c'est
la faute aux méchants et la photo mais
j'entends d'honneur à blanche
en général nous nous sommes quand vous
avons à faire les belles lettres ou
seulement très très très amis photos
glamour ou de guerre l'image a une place
importante au sein de l'adoma d'air
grâce à une équipe de photo reporter
nous ne sommes rien
ce qui compte ce sont les c'est le monde
en mouvement
nous essayons d'être à travers la
photographie les intérêts dans les
années 70 la direction du magazine à la
volonté de s'adresser à tous les
lecteurs de dien bien phu à brigitte
bardot il y en a pour tout le monde
une pluralité de sujets que défend déjà
garofalo grand reporter en 1979 dans le
trial à la fois du dramatique puis aussi
beaucoup de futile que ça vous gêne pas
si jusqu'ici les photos ont été prises
en accord avec les personnalités dans
les années 90 changement méthode alors
que les reporters critiqué auparavant
les paparazzi ils les utilisent
maintenant les mêmes méthodes exemple en
1996 la dépouille de françois mitterrand
et photographié le cliché fait scandale
pourtant en 1998 roger thérond directeur
de paris match disait n'avoir aucun
regret
parce que j'étais fier de l'avoir sierre
de jeu à trouver
d'une grande beauté esthétique je
trouvais qu'il y avait aucune raison de
ne pas publier suite à cette publication
roger thérond est condamné à cent mille
francs d'amendé les polémiques
s'enchaînent pour paris match en 2009
c'était au tour de ségolène royal de
porter plainte contre le magazine
ce sont des photos volées voilà il fait
plus donc ça serait pas dommage si on me
laissait un peu tranquille je veux
malgré cette étiquette de presse à
scandale la recette marche en 2018 les
ventes du magazine se sont élevées à un
peu plus de cinq cent mille enfants
chaque semaine contre 341 milles en
moyenne pour les 56 autres hebdomadaire
français
[Musique]